Film Courage: Can you think of an example
where you have written yourself into a corner?
And how did you write yourself out?
Jeffrey Reddick, horror screenwriter: Yeah…pretty
easy.
TAMARA was a movie I’d written myself into
a corner because the though thing in horror
films you make your villain strong and it’s
like you have to come up with a way to stop
them and you don’t want to do something
super generic but you know TAMARA was sort
of my homage to CARRIE about a girl who is
picked on and bullied and these kids pull
a prank on her and accident kill her and in
the script you know you is supposed to be
really frumpy and unattractive and then they
bury her in the woods and the next Monday
she comes back really smokin’ hot and she
knows all their secrets and she uses that
to turn against them.
But I made her, she was really powerful so
I’m like if they stop her they’re either
going to have to find a spell (since she’s
into witchcraft) they are going to have to
find a spell to stop her which is kind of
(we’ve seen that a hundred times).
And I made her so strong that you can’t
kill her because she came back from the dead,
so what do I do?
And if you haven’t seen TAMARA (a little
spoiler).
So basically I tied her fate to the teacher
that she was in love with, so he ended up
doing a heroic sacrifice, grabs Tamara and
jumps off the building with her, sacrifices
himself to stop her.
So heroic sacrifice is always a way to end
a good horror film, to get yourself out of
a corner.
But when you create a monster, you have to
find a way to kill it and then it’s like
you don’t want it to be something overly-complicated.
You don’t want it to be as simple as “Oh,
we’ll just get a spell and kill her.”
So yeah, I definitely wrote myself into a
corner with that movie and I was just like
“Well, I’ll just have the teacher sacrifice
his life to stop her.
Film Courage: And then when you got notes
(let’s say) the first few times around showing
the [the script], what were the notes?
What was the feedback about Tamara?
Was she too much this?
Not enough this?
Jeffrey: Tamara was probably the easiest,
that was probably the easiest project to as
far as we found a studio that wanted to do
it and they did it, it was a pretty easy sell.
Because I wrote that one because I wanted
to have fun with a movie, because everyone
had been like “Bring us something like FINAL
DESTINATION, bring us something…”
And then you bring something and it’s like
“Oh, that’s too much like FINAL DESTINATION.”
And it’s like “Ugh.”
So finally I just wanted to write something
fun.
And in my head I wanted to write like a fun,
quotable, campy, sexy, horror movie.
I mean it turned out really well, I did joke
that because of the budget we had a certain
budget and then magically half that budget
disappeared before the movie started shooting.
So we didn’t have the money that we went
into the movie having.
So I always kind of joke it’s like the PG-13,
ABC family version of an R-rated horror film
that I wrote.
So when you watch it, you can definitely see
like a lot of places where the story got kind
of chopped out a little bit and stuff didn’t
go like “Oh, they could have really pushed
the envelope here and they played it really
safe.”
And that was all because of budget stuff.
So that was another one where I actually wrote
a book with a friend of mine (J.D.
Matthews) we put it out based on the screenplay
just so people could see what the original
story was like because the only thing we had
to change on that because they was some really
intense stuff in there but nobody really said
to take it out and that’s what is always
funny because often times it’s the studio
that wants you to take out stuff and play
it safe and a couple of movies where that
has happened to me and it hasn’t been the
studio that has done it, either a producer
kind of running off with some money or someone
on the movie set going “Oh, let’s tone
this down.”
So I’ve had the opposite of what a lot of
people have which is where the studio wants
to play it safe.
Like I’ve had a couple movies where I’m
like I can’t believe they are letting me
get away with this.
And then you get on set and one of the actors
is like “Oh, I don’t want to do this.”
And I’m like “Dammit!
Usually the studio stops me not some actor.”
Again, it’s a very interesting business
that we’re in.
Film Courage: So having FINAL DESTINATION
and the various ones that you were a part
of under your belt, do you think that sometimes
it’s difficult because they pigeonhole you
with that and you want to do something in
a little bit of a different realm?
Or is it nice because you’re known for that
so then they have confidence [in your ability]?
Jeffrey: I mean for me it’s nice because
I’m a horror fan (I have science fiction
kind of, horror overtones to it, but a big
kind of science fiction project we are doing).
But I might branch out a little bit but I’m
very happy writing horror (I love the genre
so) and so part of it growing up was like
you would read in Fangoria Magazine which
is like which is like The Bible for horror
people, you would read directors and they’d
be like “Well, it’s not really a horror
film, it’s more of a supernatural thriller.”
And they would try to say everything but it’s
a horror film and then they would make a horror
film because they would probably make a profit
and then they would quit making horror and
go off and make other stuff.
So a lot of directors are like “Well, this
is a stepping-stone to go off and do what
I want to do.”
And so growing up you’d get like “Arrgghh,
screw you.
This is a great genre.”
And so this is something I embrace wholly.
I love going to horror conventions and it’s
a lot of fun.
There are a lot of fans, it’s a great fanbase.
And a lot of the people I work with (my peers)
were all horror fans like me and we grew up
loving the same stuff and watching the same
stuff so it’s a really fun community to
be a part of.